yep hey welcome to this video playing
Grand Master fight club from the Ukraine
that's a Ukrainian flag at least so just
have one game against them but which are
born okay do I play the same mission
let's do it as mentioned a couple of
times not the soundest of openings but
Jack interesting it leads to interesting
player that is really popular that line
I have no good reply to that I have to
admit now a form yeah well the same with
white is sort of just a blitz opening
for me that I i can now yes let me think
about this and for one moment if i go d5
he's got a form i can go eat for myself
maybe let's do that some bit dicey maybe
you can take you for now no well then
this is just a rather good position for
white that's a strange way to play it I
mean not not like brilliant for white
but I definitely think why chances are
to be preferred to you a little bit due
to the to the space
yeah g4 it's got 96 and stuff but I can
also play air for myself f and five then
F form okay I can start with this white
has to play a fourth that's some really
mandatory thing you have to make sure
that your bishops get get going and down
whoa really
what feels dangerous for black coming
going to is six okay lights is seven
maybe maybe like maybe maybe let's
reconsider here night see it looks kind
of awkward so he probably will go back
to e aid I one down I have something
better after 9895 is that repetition but
do I have anything better
interesting
interesting move okay couldn't take him
we're taking on d3 and on f4
now I'm probably threatening to take on
that file but i'm not entirely sure it
looks quite interesting in any case okay
a five quid oh okay that's not happening
now that those bishops should count for
something I was defending this position
and that looks quite awkward it's also
d6 currently constantly under pressure
check Oh Bishop f5 or how exactly it
looks it looks like the most normal move
ever but it's probably right let's see
here how to increase that pressure on d6
rookie one Queen f6 probably
maybe this year Queen f4 and then
possibly Bishop h4
I guess he didn't take that move into
account he cannot play work the eight
now the show page for just Nets the look
yeah but wait check HERE only 60 that
wins the Queen doesn't it Knight takes
Queen f7 wins the Queen rook takes us
checkmate so Chad Winns the Queen King a
jade green f8 is also made so that that
winds down a lot of tourism kind of okay
that game I don't think at least on the
surface I didn't see much wrong with
with my plane um yeah he played this f5
which is certainly um belonging into
this position I'm not totally sure about
the timing though it sometimes an idea
to um yeah to prepare it a little bit
more and 5f for felt a little bit
awkward for me to me not sure black is
really prepared for this kind of
struggle in the center as he is still
got his pieces somewhat um somewhat five
are done yeah p.m. it's it's already
tricky the engine recommends this but
this is just giving a pawn and that
cannot be too great and takes him him
and maybe not g5 wasn't such a
successful move Bishop g3 or something
but Jim yeah okay the engine wants to do
this which is also pretty strong looking
at age seven and after this you know I
was really only thinking about 96
here in this kind of situation but I can
go back and this is strong I'm just
looking at that porn and it's awkward to
defend you know I'm going here Queen age
three possibly maybe g-form that's it's
rather good now okay 94 was right rather
meek but White's position still is
better and here i don't know i mean the
comp is already on 1.3 or something it's
it's difficult for black this is
actually what the engines are suggesting
and now look at eight giving a pawn
which is very awkward yeah that's a
computer move that's that's good okay so
drop the aid is given by the engine with
a big advantage too wide but this is
probably losing on we r plus two it just
drops that porn essentially ok this is
giving the giving the coin but um the
what what is best Here I am this is what
I the the computer wants to play and
this is rather depressing ok that was a
good game i think thank for watching